people are surprised when I'm in small
settings they'll be like tell my friend
he needs to do Tick Tock and I'm like
well he doesn't I'm like hey friend what
would you like to happen in your life
well I want to Triple my business I'm
like now you have to do social but if
you didn't and you're happy then you
know clap your hands everybody Welcome
to the first episode of the marketing
scenes of success where we plant scenes
for business growth
I'm honored to introduce Our Guest for
this show
is a national entrepreneur and leader of
a massive business Empire including one
of the largest marketing agencies in the
world being a media he's a five-time New
York time best-selling author a top tier
motivation with speaker and the creator
of be friends
none other than the legendary Binger
Chuck
thank you Gary so much for joining me
today Aiden it's great to be with you my
friend yeah I miss any of your
achievements on that list
you uh you know uh yes and no yes and no
I mean we don't need to worry about
achievements I mean my achievements are
those are like the secondary things the
way the relationships I have are the
achievements so that's what I mean by
yes and I was very kind of you and I
wanted I know we don't have a lot of
time so let's get right into it to
provide value a lot so so what I love
about you Gary is that you're a
practitioner of everything you speak
about
you're you're not just living in the
clouds you operate in the dirt
which is why I think a lot of our
audience is going to benefit from
um these questions that I have for you
so you ready ready to get ready to start
I am
all right so
to start this off
I thought it would be fun to share a fun
fact
one of the reasons why I chose our
business name was in honor of you Gary
the first question is what's your
favorite color and why my favorite color
is green I don't actually know if green
became my favorite color because of the
New York Jets my favorite football team
or
that well actually I know how I picked
the jet so that wasn't it was Eric
Godfrey my friend said you're a Jets fan
I think it's because of the New York
Jets though I gotta find there's some
sort of like piece of paper my mom has
like for me from kindergarten which was
before I liked the Jets where I think
green is my favorite color so I've got
to figure that out
love it all right so moving into the
marketing stuff about the important
stuff
what are your thoughts in the economy
right now and how an ambitious business
owner should navigate that especially a
contractor yeah I'm not a economist so
I'm not I'm coming from a complete guess
what do I feel I feel that
there's just a lot of instability in the
world right there's there's war in
Europe there's
a huge shift in the way the world
communicates between social and
traditional media there's clearly uh
East versus West scenario between China
and America that continues to get more
strategic
if not contentious you know you've got
alliances bricks right Brazil Russia
India China South Africa
um is a real economic Alliance now that
is something that the U.S and
Europe can't ignore that leads to like
different actions different
instabilities
um I think that there is incredible lack
of people saving money you know the
coolness of saving money of the 50s and
60s has become not cool people live on
credit
people buy things they can't afford
so that's always scary and I think you
know companies are in Shake you know an
interesting part you're seeing a lot of
the big tech companies lay people off
and a lot of people are like what the
hell they have record savings they have
record dollars why are they laying
people off it's not like they're laying
people off to like survive it's that we
just have a lot of inefficiencies
technology and over hiring during covid
have just created inefficiency like no
matter how good or bad you feel about
running a business if you think that
there might be issues in front of you
you'd rather get ahead of them right
it's like you know why why are companies
laying people off they haven't had a
heart attack yet well if you don't eat
the wrong things and if you exercise you
can prevent a heart attack so like I
feel like we're in very interesting
times I would say an ambitious small
business should make sure that they have
a just in case fund so like don't
overextend yourself be sitting on cash
to the best of your ability
a little a little Nest Egg but don't be
frozen by fear like be on the offense if
you're good like if you're good you'll
pick up business during tough times
because your competitors will lose their
business to you and so you know with
Vayner we're trying to be thoughtful but
we're also trying to be on the offense
and pick up market share
agree same same here same logic here
love it is Word of Mouth
alone by itself
a reliable way to grow a business
especially again for a local contractor
like a landscaper
you know what they can afford on social
media because I think or Google because
I think it will search your social will
help them grow
but you know I'm not going to sit here
and say you have to run marketing
there's too many people watching right
now who've only Built their business on
Word of Mouth word of mouth is powerful
my big point about that is like why
wouldn't you want to double your
business if you could afford it and it
didn't create
anything negative for you like work-life
balance like why would you know like
it's kind of like that Facebook movie
right like you know what's better than a
million a billion kind of thing like
that whole thing it's like yes you can
build a three million dollar a year
landscaping business with just word of
mouth because you have a big enough
wealthy enough area where you're the guy
you're the gal for the last decade my
question is like why wouldn't you want
it to be 5.3 million because you were
good at Facebook and Google
of word of mouth in a lot of ways
especially with social of course it is
it just it goes back to one's ambition
like people are surprised when I'm in
small settings where like there'll be
like 10 of us and they're like tell my
friend that he needs to do you know
Tick-Tock and I'm like you know like
well he doesn't I'm like hey friend what
would you like to happen in your life
well I want to Triple my business I'm
like now you have to do social yeah but
if you didn't and you're happy then you
know clap your hands
you know smaller company
when is the right time to start looking
for a marketing provider like an agency
or
a freelancer and what what should you
look for in that provider
um that I think is a lot to do with word
of mouth or examples so let's just be
very direct in your world anybody who's
watching and considering your shop they
should talk to your current and former
clients
and see what they like and there's not a
single service provider that doesn't
have clients that have had negative
experience like I think we're the best
and there's plenty of people like yeah
it didn't work for us and it might be
casting it might be them we might have
had a bad day they might have had a bad
day like so there's that and and then as
far as considering it I think it's one
of two extremes you want to be on
defense you're worried that the economy
is going to get worse and you're going
to lose 25 of your clients so you want
to go on the offense or defense
depending on how you want to look at it
to grow or it's pure offense like you're
feeling great you're not even worried
about a recession and you just want to
double because you want to because you
want to have a bigger business for
whatever reasons the vanity you need the
money to pay for your mom in her nursing
home like there's like I people always
forget about all the reasons one would
want and so by the way you just want to
go to nicer vacations with your family
while your kids are still in the house
and aren't gonna you know when they move
out you're never going to have 11 and 8
eight-year-old again and you just want a
nicer vacation a longer one a fancier
one I don't care like everyone gets to
choose what they want so you know if
that's the case well then you need to
grow your business and marketing oh is
how you grow a business
yeah they got it how would you so a lot
more uh again a lot of our clients are
smaller uh really out in the field
working a lot yeah the job
what are some
some things they can do to get
themselves out of the field and then
actually working on the business side of
things well that's a big one in your
world I think almost everyone who's got
a
you know Hefty six-figure seven figure
landscaping business
isn't hiring enough people to get them
out of the field
that's my next question I mean it was my
biggest argument with my dad when I had
a small liquor store I was like Dad if
I'm behind the register I can't be on
the computer to make business grow
same thing
my dad was like I want you on the floor
and at the register I'm like I want to
be in this little office with a glass
pane watching the floor in the register
while I'm on the computer growing the
business
so how do you find good employees to
work in the hot sun and and retain them
you find them by guessing
literally you just hire people and then
you get to see what they're like you
retain them by communicating with them
and finding out what they value whether
that's money work life balance
even just caring about you know the the
Mendoza Line the threshold for being
good in this industry because I've
followed this industry for a long time
isn't very high there's so many people
that don't even have any kind of
relationship with the people in the
field and then there's people that are
incredibly good at having relationships
and appeal because they're in the field
and it's just about caring about your
employee
yes sir all right let me uh let me thank
you Gary for for coming on here thanks
for having me brother I went a little
bit over so no worries I I bought us a
couple minutes my next meeting's here so
I'm gonna run I love you Aiden I wish
you well
[Music]